Venter corn professor Pinto corn did
come out with a video statement
yesterday and I know you were listening
to it you're monitoring it and the
takeaway seemed to be that he was
holding firm he didn't want to make any
move just then what do you think
transpired between yesterday and today
well he had meetings with the executive
committee there are five people on that
board normally there six of those five
people he didn't apparently have enough
and enough support to go on to the full
board which was always expected to
extend his contract as of last week on
Friday on Friday he was supposed to give
this two year contract extension through
2018 for dr. Martin Winterkorn who has
lived
otto's who has lived Volkswagen his
entire life this last week has been a
stunning at turnaround it has been
remarkable in every way and what he says
now is that he's resigning in part he's
not accepting he's accepting personally
personal responsibility he isn't saying
that even though he's done anything
wrong but he thinks the new CEO should
have a clear slate to move forward to
rebuild the company that rebuilding is
going to have two parts one it's going
to be focusing on the legal litigation
that hurdles and two the technical
challenges of how you fix this problem
vinter corn thought he could do the
technical side of that that's pretty
clear looks like the board didn't have
the support or the confidence that he
could do this second part which has
turned the brand around now we have to
figure out who the next CEO is the two
candidates that we think are very close
a Herbert Dees he recently came over
from BMW now he's running the Volkswagen
brand one of the twelve brands and then
of course Mateus Muller Mateus Muller is
the CEO of Porsche one thing about
Porsche though you know they sold about
a hundred and ninety thousand vehicles
last year the Volkswagen Group as a
whole
sold ten million vehicles now that said
when you look at Porsches profits they
had three billion in profit last year
the Volkswagen brand itself had about
2.5 so they go with Porsche they're
going with a luxury profit Center